do you understand who's next
you understand what it means to be next
you got your prospectus do a ton of
podcasts as a guest but doing the effort
of then going into creating your own you
still think it's a viable channel with
all the noise oh I do I do because I do
think it's a game of best versus a game
of first you know like I think your take
on a healthy economy from a franchisee
thing is very important because it leads
to people saving more money like there's
a lot of good that comes from you know
one of the reasons I wanted to take this
meeting and like I I think it's very
important in the history of
entrepreneurship in America for more
actual entrepreneurs to get more of the
percentage of the voice because there's
a lot of misinformation and a lot of the
fakeness that comes along with this
right now
yeah that's why how long you have the
first truck first truck for three years
I need that story brother brother I love
that story
yeah like anybody watching us right now
we're listening or whatever they're
gonna do with the content or when you do
this and they hear 370 million
thirty-year but three years you have one
[ __ ] truck in franchise till ten
years in took me eight years to get to a
million in revenue we do it until you
you know but that's the slow and steady
and everyone in this Instagram world
wants right away yeah and they always
did everyone's blaming social me I guess
what we're old enough to know they
always did
it's why they watched infomercials at
night that's why they [ __ ] they always
did
patience or when they do they're so
flabbergasted why they've worked so hard
for nine days and nothing's happened yet
so eight years to a million thirty years
by the way that's what this is yeah you
know like this is one big version of
that for me too
you know like like same thing with like
Wine Library like it you know it like
took years to build something like this
is just a foundation building for my
next day you try to get followers yeah
there's only one way if I do a normal
post and I tell everybody to follow
otherwise you'll get 12 49 103 when I'd
say you know when I tell them to follow
you yeah otherwise you'll get seven
twelve fifty a hundred can you keep my
dad entertained so I can bang through
these employees real quick make a piece
of help I make a piece of content that
will go viral you have to you guys have
to teach him right now create a fake
account create a secondary account on
his phone right now like and literally
spending you've got time literally spend
and you got budget like figure out like
your I know but you're busy like let's
figure out or it could be you I don't
give a [ __ ] he has to practice like he
has the post 30 times in a row on a fake
account creator right now put his
secondary switch it over on his phone
make him do everything show him at and
and and repetitive repetitive repetitive
repetitive for two hours and then he'll
get it are you guys hello good to see
you
radio a pleasure Ben hi
it's time I'm ready to get to work okay
so can you get somebody to help us so we
don't waste them yeah so I get back and
talk them love any sign that same ones
Barney you know I like you know it's
funny you picked up on that I'm a fan of
kids just like it I like the city a lot
plus I'm I like the Chiefs in a weird
way I hate well no I mean I hate the
Chiefs but like yeah because I hate
everybody but the Jets but but I have
empathy for chief fans because they're
basically the same as the Jets no way
you can win so much my friend so much
mainly because I think if I completely
put if I can pull it off boy will it
become something that a lot of people
long after I'm dead can use as a
framework because because it's not just
that I pull it off it's that I'm gonna
be one of the first people ever to fully
document the thirty years of patience
and hard work it took I missed a period
of my you know journey but like you know
I'm gonna buy them in 25 years that's a
lot of content you know it's just gonna
it's gonna educate people like you know
you hear about things like she was a
little girl and now she did this company
but you you're missing the 41 years that
she broke her back I'm documenting it so
you know it's funny when a really weird
moment that's Super Bowl this weekend me
AJ and D Rock and Tyler watched some
episodes of daily be from three years
ago it was really fascinating oh my god
go back oh my god this is incredible
ready nope go back to the look at this
look at the camera
Wow already and that's only three years
like AJ hates my content isn't my
brother he's like I don't watch any of
it doesn't need it he lived it but he
[Music]
and also what's the strategy of like if
you like I really want to make sure that
a few film then Dustin can film today
because then you could be working on
post yeah I really think nobody should
feel them back-to-back days nobody
should film back-to-back days got it
it's just I want it fast I want it fast
it's gonna work
all right here take it there they are
what's up guys a hundred percent before
before we get into it yeah before we get
into a question or two I want to give
you guys the opportunity I thank you so
much for supporting the case wisss and I
want to make sure you guys get a chance
to uh to promote your guys event which I
know you guys have worked real hard to
get like I the amount of hustle that you
guys have used to try to get me there I
appreciate I also preach I'm really
proud of myself you're not gonna want to
hear this but three or four years ago
when somebody tried as hard as you guys
did even though it wasn't the right
amount of dollars and I had things going
on I would always bend and break because
I respected it so much so I'm glad I've
been able to say no consistently to you
guys because that's something I actually
had to work on but nonetheless tell
everybody a little bit about your event
its we put together a little recap of
what we did to get you to your event we
just want to show you that and then love
it I'm ready okay all right this is how
you get Gary Vee to speak at your event
Gary charges 250 K plus first-class
travel for one keynote money but we are
broke so we have to find another way
step one get two thousand people really
hyped about the
[Applause]
dog his insta stories to figure out when
and where he will arrive at the airport
yeah give him some presents and then
pitch him we're from Germany he came all
the way here today we had been this year
is two and a half thousand people two
days five thousand people Mike Tyson as
a headline speaker that's awesome when
is it 27th and 28th of April I will
actually try I'm interested in coming
you catch me at a good time because
now's a club CA we're starting bigger
speakers we want to build it up so I'm
gonna speak for next year but I'm gonna
want to do is say I'll take less money
you know I'm 250 and you offer 150 I'll
say give me a hundred give 50 to these
two people because they now work with
Boehner speakers so I'm going to be
motivated next year to spaz eeeh we'll
be in touch I believe you I can feel the
energy step 3 order 35 pairs of Gary's
clouds and dirt sneakers to get a
5-minute Instagram live with him contact
Barney the CEO of K Swiss to discuss
ideas on how to get Gary to your event
oh and by the way I also offered to name
my son Gary promised it to Gary
signature on my arm step 4 fly to New
York City to drop off some of your
hottest merch at the offices of
vaynermedia ad-rock
thanks for the Instagram story step 5
get Geoff Nicholson the CMO of
vaynermedia on your podcast and ask him
for advice how could we pitch Gary as a
speaker for event and how can you help
us to do so I will publicly tag him with
you on a post in the near future to see
if I can get his attention so at least I
get you some awareness to seal the deal
get a loan from the bank in offering
100k for one keynote speech or 10k for
video conference that will surely get
him yeah the big guys what this video
didn't show is the biggest mistake you
made which is you scheduled your
conference during the NFL Draft which is
the most important time for me and AJ at
Vayner sports like honestly and I think
you could tell through my eyes like I
wanted to like kind of reward you right
now you [ __ ] up on the NFL Draft but
you didn't know that
that's a big problem I think look here's
what I would say if you guys work with
me on dates for 2020 for sure I feel
very confident that we can get some
coming we we can get something done but
I but I don't want to I don't want to
promise right now when I don't know
[Music]
thank you
you know what's crazy though at just the
beginning yeah this is where people get
[ __ ] up a little bit right like I was
talking to somebody the other day I was
like their album didn't go as well as
they wanted to yeah and keep going like
that oh my god I was like drop a [ __ ]
mixtape next week and one song can shoot
your life so get gassed for it
yes but like Britta sir like honestly
don't get too high or too low
yeah it's gonna be what its gonna be you
could have a song in there too changes
your life forever or it just might be
solid guys I know what's gonna be good
yeah it's not gonna be like oh no it's
not I already know just cuz I've
listened to another like it's not gonna
be like you're finished it just like
people understand how building blocks
work so much footage together we got
stuck we got the footage when he didn't
[Music]
we're in the studio we got the party do
you understand who's next you understand
what it means to be next right here
[Music]
correct correct
a huge thing for me which i think is
super unique and I don't think is a
practical advice for everybody but like
Jesus if you can if you can make your
money in a way that allows you to be
better to your audience and to your
employees
you've got leverage and that's what I
have so I think getting a sense of like
what are you actually up to is super
important and if you're like I love what
I do well then you should invest in that
beast forever if you're like I just want
some money and buy a home in Jamaica and
live there well then maximize it and
squeeze it I think it's a very important
thing I just don't think most people
know what they're doing when I say know
what they're doing I mean macro like why
do you have this business it doesn't
it's it's a lifestyle business this is a
legacy is this you want to make as much
money as possible flip it and do
something else like if you are honest
with yourself and everybody around you
employees will work for you if you tell
them that you're gonna drive everybody
into the ground and flip it because some
of them may say well I just need the
[ __ ] paycheck or they may say oh cool
I want to be in flipped or cool I just
want to watch her do it and then maybe
I'll do it like truth really is good
it's really really
[Music]